honest is good i think the the note that
you just mentioned right the idea that
we are outside
there's no idea that this is going to
stop us after being out here right i
think the idea that we all haven't had a
good time enjoying each other's company
but i think it's the reason for why
we're definitely out here there's the
spirit of mlk
and the need for us to be out here is
even more important and being outside
just makes even better yeah i mean the
energy is good the music's out there's a
good turnout for different organizations
i mean it's pretty exciting absolutely i
think that's the idea the fact that we
have multiple organizations here that
has stood out as we were walking in
there was a couple of individuals who
came from texas and they wanted to take
pictures with us because they kind of
figured we'll step us but just even
seeing that energy from the young
students made it even worthwhile
tell me the importance of
today the importance of recognizing mlk
we've been doing it since 1983 but why
is today this year still so it's so
important
very much i'm so important when you
think about the this recent discussion
related to voting rights and we think
about how mlk strive to actually make
that very possible for us but civil
rights in general i think it's important
for us to recognize the importance of
that just by us being out here and
relating that this is something for us
to come out bringing that same energy to
coming out for voting rights as well so
i can only imagine this is going to
continue for the rest of the year in
terms of the perception
tell me the impact of the parade the
parade here in las vegas you know las
vegas history as far as you know civil
rights and racial yeah equality we had
the moulin rouge agreement you know so
this um you know as far as black people
working on the strip casino so tell me
the importance of the impact of this
parade especially here in las vegas
the idea that there's multiple different
organizations that represent the black
culture within vegas and the idea that
they are showing themselves out in many
ways
from individuals who are part of whether
it's rtc or whether state farm or
whether it's mgm we're quite quite
frankly small business owners even the
general idea that you have survivors you
know coming in and flow is kind of
cutting here that level of culture and
what it brings to the vegas organization
or vegas state
is something i think is very important
for us to recognize as well yeah and
there's a lot of kids out here oh yeah
good to see you know kids out here teams
out here
as i mentioned so recently like when we
had a couple kids coming through and
even us as an organization we do have a
couple of mentors and it's something to
when they see people who look like them
striving the way that they strive and
being out here it's that energy that
makes the organic all worthwhile right
there's a reason why we're doing what
we're doing and what i want to look for
in the future is the idea of seeing them
come through and bringing on this same
energy moving forward
what do you think dr king would think of
you know this parade i mean it's not
just black people out here people of all
races latino wyatt asian so what do you
think he would think of this parade the
idea that we were all walking collecting
together with the same feeling same
happened insane energy i think what he
would literally say is a job well done
and i think for us even as point being
part of our fraternity organization
that's something that we also came to
mind our minds and strive for as well
but i think what he would definitely say
this is probably the most beautiful
sight he's ever seen
in las vegas
and um also what would you say there's
some folks who are at home who didn't
make it out what would you tell them to
get them to come out and support or just
even be a spectator for next year i
think at the end of the day you know
there's some recognition i would say
maybe people didn't come out for
different reasons right and one of them
being concerns obviously was what's
going to happen but i think there's
still the energy that they can
definitely see as viewers but more
importantly is they still come out
whether again it's physically have a
good time socially but also to recognize
the point of today but as i mentioned
before there's some after voting rights
as well that i think should be
considered and making sure that never
hinders our ability to still exercise
all right to enjoy and do what we need
to do
when you're when you look across the sea
of people you know how would you
describe it oh man a multiple facet of
different faces and races and creed and
religions and beliefs and honestly it's
beautiful and it's one of those things
when you just see it
and you feel at peace walking through
there's no concern no tension
that's beautiful honestly beautiful day
out
anything else
want to say honestly it's good to be out
here um again as i said the vice
president chapter of alpha five return
incorporated uh we're coming in full
force
of course we're specifically all the
divine eye organizations but alpha phi
alpha uh we're definitely here as well
and you all kind of felt there were some
there's a king committee so do you help
with the king committee or do you all
have your own events that you're doing a
bit of both right so there's many
individuals who are representing the
organization that do help with the king
committee but in our way we actually had
a couple of events this past weekend as
well whether it's to
recognize a one of our brothers who
passed away we also kicked off an mlk
breakfast this morning as well so
there's different things that we're
making sure that we're doing to kind of
commemorate the actual data as well